[Music]
okay some more spicy news here in what
my sign news
submitted by adult Disney okay
a woman was not allowed to rent a room
due to her astrological sign is that
called a Horus horoscope is a horse of
Horus yes you're Pisces sorry you
another we own this [ __ ] hotel no
it's not a hotel it's for a roommate Oh
your roommate and so I get it yeah
so this woman she was applying to be a
roommate right unless you receive this
message that looks like this on Facebook
Dom would you like to read it
sure hey Christine exclamation mark
obviously off to a crazy start okay
sorry I haven't responded earlier period
my concern is that you're a Capricorn oh
my god our main goal is to keep things a
would I don't know without anyone being
in charge or dumbing the household ID on
the household okay sort of making sense
this okay I love capricorns doesn't
sound like it but I don't think I could
live with one in parentheses or being a
band with another one was it bad karma
that means the copied and pasted this
share this Virgo / Gemini house is a
special place where soft mute mute
herbal said Mew in circus that would be
more accurate signs get to run free
untethered by cardinal authorities
totally lost me that at the end not a
night not a clue what she's saying is
this the Cardinal Thor he's at the band
I wish you well on your search and hope
you are doing okay exclamation mark yeah
she dodged a bullet on that one that
that
[ __ ] funny how obnoxious was that
message you're a Capricorn
so this took place in Portland so that's
my song sounds about right
anywhere there's hippies and did you
start bands indiscriminately that yeah
looking for a roommate slash band member
yeah oh my god so this screenshot was
tweeted with the caption or sorry with
yeah we're catching [ __ ] astrology
queers in this town are out of control
y'all because it's like so is there a
lot of astrology peoples she was looking
so apparently she seems to be lesbian
and she was looking for roommates with
the LGBTQ background and this is a very
narrow filter where Zillow do you go to
this like looking for roommate who is
gay and the Capricorn and wants to start
a [ __ ] band even a Capricorn isn't or
whatever it is you know so when you go
shopping for clothes then you have 13
filters on it it just goes from two
thousand three thousand one hundred yeah
so this article that I have here they
kind of explained things so capricorns
are this is so funny but they pretty
much separate horse goat or astrology
whatever into three things okay so now
now we're believing it right no but just
if you wanted to just to play around to
the [ __ ] Sun action yeah according to
this astrologer they said that's
Capricorn since they're from December
and January they assure in the cold
winter months and they're often seen or
considered as rigid and industrious
you're right it does make sense now that
I think about it it sounds like a
delicious by super [ __ ] industrious
yeah which is not gonna happen yes so
then zodiacs are grouped into three
qualities Cardinal mutable and fixed and
what's yeah what's Cardinal Cardinal is
like the beginning of a Lois
the signs that are the beginning of
every season so they're considered to be
more likely to initiate action according
to this and then mutable signs like
Virgo and gentlemen I are the signs at
end of season and are generally
considered to be more flexible and
adaptable yeah so that's what that all
mean what's way what's the other one
[ __ ] fixed not to snip oh they can't
which is why why are there them this is
like the hottest thing right now that I
mean that this [ __ ] though is actually
[ __ ] accurate we're all talking about
this kinds of [ __ ] and then we see why
we have turbulent [ __ ] relationships
we're like all right just for shits and
giggles let's see what the [ __ ] and then
we look at it and it's all true but just
kind of throw out there it seems like
these the ones causing the turbulence it
doesn't seem like you know when I look
for a roommate all of a sudden I'm
getting text messages like this yeah
just saying are these let me guess these
they're there it's a guy two guys it's
see from the tiny little photo it looks
like it's a guy it is yeah oh my god
this is some fever last behavior yeah
they're gay though Christina Christina
the girl playing okay yeah but see like
this this is like the hottest thing that
you see on Twitter like every I say six
or seven tweets it's about some kind of
astrological tweet talking about oh go
back in time well this is just weird
because like measles before people are
so interesting because like how I see it
is this is like we're wearing this age
we're like I don't want labels you can't
label me I can be whoever whatever I
want but the Sun but the Sun it's all
good label me [ __ ] oh but you're like
this because you're like this people are
so [ __ ] fickle dude it's like you
pick what side of the fence you're on if
you want to be whatever the [ __ ] you
want be that person but then you can't
also say that because you were born at a
certain time whatever that you're now
predestined to be this type of human
yeah it's just like don't be a dick or
be a dick the reason why when I was
younger I didn't believe that [ __ ] is
because number one especially with your
you know like the Asian zodiac signs
yeah so I was found because I am
actually a year young
and I thought I was because my mom
[ __ ] up my birth certificate when I
came to the States so if that was true
then all these traits that they said I
wasn't okey thing which was a rabbit
they said this is why that's cute cookie
sonís rabbit so I'm supposed to be this
rabbit and all these trace up till now
they're like oh you should have been a
rabbit and they said all these traits
were who I was
turns out not even a rabbit though what
are you a turtle right what you're I
think I'm a tiger or dragon you just
wants you to be just a dragon guys this
whole time has just been a dragon yeah
I'm a dragon or a tiger or some [ __ ]
like that and excited about the lunar
calendar - yeah Pinzon what
yeah month yes 88 no 87 I am actually 88
oh you're a dragon yes I'm a dragon so
what the [ __ ] was this whole time where
everybody has told me I had the
attributes of a rabbit see you're not a
[ __ ] after all no rabbits are not a
[ __ ] and my book they're [ __ ] and I
you're not a [ __ ] a third thing oh
thank you compliment
wait where's like the the base idea for
this well it's like did the Greeks come
up with so many people believe you're
like oh obviously it makes sense because
you know there's the Sun like where's
the thing that connects it to something
that makes sense I don't know I think it
has something to do with the the stars
planetary alignment a different I think
it's like the the Stars changing and
moving and then so does your mood and
energy because it's tied to that but how
do you when do you factor in the
alcoholic father that every day he was
probably a pisces dream I'm saying it's
weird
it's because it's a way in my personal
being how I see it it's a way for people
to not want to be responsible for the
things that they do
accountability out the window I don't be
fixed I'm stuck I'm stubborn cuz imma
Aries you know good Oh Larry like or you
could you just have a bad trait that you
should probably fix that you can fix you
know yeah and so every time there's like
a bad trade now it's like oh it's that's
not my responsibility
yeah I was born under the [ __ ] moon
there's a beep does it have to be when
you were born or when you were
when you were the montior born or you
know when you when your mom kind of
thieve that's true yeah what about that
cuz that seems pretty important you know
when you when your dad said that nuttin
that your birth name that seems pretty
important that's true
and what style your dad did it it to
that's you know because if your mom's
belly is facing down there's a different
type of sperm gravity forties are
bouncing upwards is a different question
question marks all around can't really
figure that one out but I think I'm not
a Capricorn so I can join the band
that's true not a cat that is wild
cuz it you should be something that
people would do for fun and now if you
till is fun for me
now now it's becoming something where
people are sledge it's serious at Bailey
so people are gonna start having seances
and [ __ ] going around in the source I
got rejected from housing yeah yeah are
you serious you know it's crazy to
that's illegal right I was about to say
that you know how we have discrimination
laws yeah this doesn't count as a job
yeah cuz it's not one of the sixteen
protected classes or categories you're
Astro astrology yeah not [ __ ] yeah
it's all twenty people are gonna own
businesses soon these people already do
and bands music we'll listen to the
infiltrating us guys like rats which
brings it all full circle because the
plague and measles and going back and
down you and it kind of sucks to that
people already have a certain
predisposition about who you are as a
person based on when you were born
like what that was your birthday or one
of them Oh like what's up [ __ ]
it's it's actually better because then
you get to realize that they're one of
those Thank You Celia
you don't like logic yeah rudiness
article made me really believe the whole
astrology thing is even more yes because
the people in my life that I've known
that are like really sweet and caring
and
really emotionally connected our
capricorns and the way they make
capricorns out in this article it's like
they're totally not like they're all
typing nice ice [ __ ] at least not the
capricorns that i know that are in my
life they're not like that at all so
that's why you can't expect everyone
from that whole month or two months or
whatever it is to be the same
personality but that's when they came up
with the whole rising sign and other
signs and it they're like well that's
because your day is different
yeah position that you're a lot it's a
lot guys with velocity and what was a
rotation when the [ __ ] sperm started
coming what were you drinking you won't
be drunk off of this big that should
actually be the thing what what your
parents are drunk off of when they
conceived you I do wonder how they came
up with it though because the Chinese
have their own style the Greeks have
theirs I mean it makes sense for back in
the day it was just easy to make some
[ __ ] out and then just tie the knots
problems in ayahuasca jitters and uh
[Music]